ó fui para cada lugar Tu é doido meu
chama fui para a Irlanda Irlanda Não sei
nem por qual é o rumo daí se você mandar
a ponta para Irlanda eu vou dizer macho
pega aí a BR aqui desce vai direto vai
direto direto eu não sei eu nunca pensei
nele eu fui pra Irlanda cara sem saber
um pingo de inglês mandei mensagem para
o cara falei E aí tá tudo certo para eu
chegar o cara disse não tá tudo certo eu
chegar lá no aeroporto o transfer vai
estar te esperando aí eu falei aí mano o
trânsito você vai estar esperando aí
cheguei lá o cara tava lá eu e aí
transfer como é que tá meu irmão eu
pensava que era o nome do cara que era
sei lá dona de